so thanks for having me it's a pleasure
being at this workshop
obviously we're talking about things in
the larger rubric of climate and health
and I wanted to give some of the sort of
like philosophical thinking's about the
the ideas of climate and health climate
infectious disease in particular and I
just wanted to put forth the notion that
you know climate and disease is not a
new notion to a certain extent ok this
is the oldest reference I've ever come
across to malaria if you make it all the
way to the seventh book of the history
of the Peloponnesian War by Thucydides
you'll see him talking about the
destruction of the Athenian expedition
at Syracuse in 413 bc and he wrote this
in about 40 6 bc and he says i'll just
read it after a particularly devastating
battle the athenian generals consulted
upon the disaster which had happened and
upon the general weakness of the army
they saw themselves unsuccessful in
their enterprises and the soldiers
disgusted with her stay disease being
rife among them owing to its being the
sickly season of the year and to the
marshy and unhealthy nature of the spot
in which they were in camped and in that
last clause right there he's describing
malaria he doesn't know what it is he
doesn't know how its transmitted there's
no germ theory they don't know that
mosquitoes are the vector of it but he's
pinpointing the fact that it was
recognized that marshy areas were
unhealthy and at particular times of the
year in particular summer in Sicily it
was particularly unhealthy so there's a
recognition that human health and
disease were inextricably linked to the
environment including the climate going
back almost 2500 years now if you were
to run forward into the 16th century 16
17 18th centuries in Europe obviously
there's a field of medical geography and
a lot of what they were trying to do
there was sort of catalog and understand
what's going on with the patterns of
disease and there was an understanding
that there were certain waters and
certain airs that were helpful and there
were less that were less healthy and
there's a rich vocabulary in the English
language and I'm sure other European
languages describing these different
types of things and the the notion of
the spa sort of came back into vogue the
people will go certain areas to get to
more healthful climates places where it
was just a better place to live so now
of course we have this increasing
intention on the effects of climate
variability in global warming on human
health and what's going to happen and
the picture of course is variable as to
what's going to happen in the future
it's not
single monolithic change in temperature
the hydrologic cycle for instance and
one of the things that people look at
one of the issues that we have to deal
with is try to look at it beyond just
the broadest terms and I'm not trying to
disparage anything here I'm actually
going to be echoing some things that
Mercedes was talking about earlier but
if you were to look at what we have here
on the Left what you have is a picture
of the increase of global average
temperatures over 125 period your period
you see a rise in that you also have a
picture right here I'll use the pointer
of the distribution of malaria as it
currently stands upper right there
that's the anopheles gambiae I'm
mosquito which is principal vector
malaria and sub-saharan Africa or ninety
percent of malaria transmission occurs
now that mosquito has an optimal
temperature range intolerance it's been
fairly well established in laboratory
studies it's got a a window of minimum
and maximum temperatures at which its
thrives it gets warmer but not too warm
it's going to complete its extrinsic
incubation cycle very well for the
pathogen within it it's also going to
complete its gon a trophic cycle and lay
its eggs it's going to sort of
accelerate the whole process by which it
goes through biting acquiring pathogen
laying its eggs than going seeking
another host meal and potentially
transmitting to the next person so one
of the things people thought about
initially was well if global
temperatures are warming and if Europe
and Asia and North America become more
and more like what it's like in
sub-saharan Africa the anopheles gambiae
I mosquito could get on a plane come off
and find that New Haven Connecticut it's
pretty hospitable in a hundred years and
then it's going to set up camp and it's
going to go around and and do its
business another thing people have
looked at initially Mercedes obviously
showed much more detailed an elegant
work on this was looking at the fact
that there's association between El Nino
and what's going on with cholera
outbreaks and the thing is about it is
that when we talk about climate we think
about climate we think about it at very
long time scales and we typically that
we don't need to think about it very
large spatial scales but the fact of the
matter is the spatial scales at which
these diseases take place the spatial
scales that is experienced by the
infectious disease the perceptual scale
of a vector of the
disease like a mosquito is very small
they have a very small world they live
in and if we're going to understand
what's going on at that we have to marry
across those scales and we have to start
thinking about things beyond large scale
patterns of change and look at more
localized hydrologic and meteorological
variability my contention is that if we
can understand that at a more localized
scale we can then build up to it and
then factor in those projections and
figure out what's going on so to think
about it again if we just take this
example malaria once more we would not
need to just think about this global
pattern of warming and what that's going
to do to temperatures across broad swath
subcontinent's we have to think about
the local rainfall we have to think
about the local temperature changes the
local humidity changes and the local
environment and the other thing that we
have to do and again this echoes what
mercede says we can't think about
climate and health in a bubble we have
to think about all the other factors
that actually impinge on an effect and
modulate rates of disease transmission
we need to think about the biology we
need to think about the genetics we need
to think about the medical public health
infrastructure land-use socio-economic
conditions we have eight species of the
genus anopheles here in the North
America that can transmit malaria but we
don't have malaria anymore it's because
we drained our swabs we manage those
resources we paved over tons of areas we
build constructions and buildings like
this with air-conditioned systems and
good screens and what not to keep
insects out of them we husband our
animals and other places for the most
part other side from our pets and so
we've really segregated ourselves from
the mosquitoes and when we do that we we
cut off the transmission cycle that is
vital for the sustenance and the
sustained transmission of a pathogen
such as malaria you know by all accounts
Houston should be a malaria zone but
people go from their air conditioned
house to their air-conditioned car to
their condition workplace and when they
see a mosquito they swat it so you would
need a break down in that socio-economic
conditions the medical the public health
infrastructure I would argue before you
would actually see some effective
temperature necessarily manifesting as a
change in malaria rates by the
introduction of mosquito so we have to
think about it in that larger context
all right
so off my soapbox and I'm going to talk
about West Nile virus a bit so West Nile
virus is a mosquito-borne disease it's a
flam enviros that's similar to Japanese
encephalitis virus in the United States
at this point we're getting up to 10,000
clinical cases per year which manifest
as meningitis encephalitis and a more
milder form something that's called West
Nile fever something that doesn't
penetrate into the meninges across the
blood-brain barrier the majority of
cases though are not actually documented
clinically because they're mild or
subclinical and people don't actually
seek medical attention for it so there
are a lot more cases per year than that
10,000 would indicate okay at present
there's no vaccine available for humans
there's an echo invite vaccine out there
but the CDC does not recommend that you
go out and buy it and take it the West
vial not nice the West Nile virus
transmission cycle is summarizing the
schematic right here and what it
consists of is the ZOA nautic loop right
here of transmission between Pollux
genus mosquitoes that are vectors and
typically avian hosts so what happens is
that a mosquito comes along it bites an
infected host that has a hive I remya
tix on the blood meal it gets infected
with the virus after a certain period of
time that's referred to as the extrinsic
incubation psyche period it the virus
has multiplied with in mosquito hosts
and his move to the salivary glands if
the mosquito survives lays its eggs she
can then go on and seek another host
meal which you'll use the blood for to
feed the next batch of eggs and in doing
so when she feeds on another bird she
can pass that virus on to the bird so we
have this this transmission cycle going
on in north america since the
introduction of West Nile virus and
because of this we're never really going
to get rid of the virus we're never
going to keep birds and mosquitoes apart
so we could something that we're going
to have to deal with for a long time I
would suspect now in addition we have
these things right here this is
sometimes referred to as spillover
transmission or incidental infection
where sometimes referred to as dead end
hosts and these are other organisms such
as people and horses that can be
infected with West Nile virus so should
one of these infected mosquitoes bite us
we can become very sick from it in some
instances now we don't run a high end of
viremia to pass it back to a mesquite
so we're not participating in this
transmission loop that sustains it
within the environment hence were
sometimes called the dead end host so
West Nile virus first appeared in North
America in 1999 in New York City that
year there were 62 cases of West Nile
virus all within the New York State and
there was a little bit of evidence in
avian animal mosquito infections and
some surrounding states in that first
year so one of the questions at that
point was well how quickly was it going
to spread and as we found out it spread
fairly quickly across the whole
continent so this is what the picture
looked like in two thousand you can see
it spread up the north eat down the
Northeast Corridor a bit more but still
you're not getting too many human
infections here's 2001 it spread all the
way past the Mississippi River saturated
Mississippi River Valley essentially
it's all the way down to Florida here's
2002 it's made it all the way to the
west coast and then 2003 have some big
outbreaks almost 3,000 cases in Colorado
almost 2,000 cases in Nebraska and it's
basically saturated the whole country at
this point there's 2004 if you pull up
any more the CDC map since then it's
it's pervasive throughout the country so
here's some plots for a to the states
California Colorado Florida Idaho etc
showing you the pattern through time in
total number cases of West Nile virus
fever and sefa lightest or meningitis
has reported through the CDC on an
annual basis and what you can see is
that there's sort of some evidence that
in the first year or two sometimes it's
three sometimes it's a little more after
introduction there's a large outbreak
initially a pulse in the fully
susceptible population into which the
virus has been introduced followed by
somewhat lower levels of sustained
transmission that sort of indicates sort
of settling into a pattern of endemicity
however we have had returns and spikes
so if you look at new york where first
arrived you can see that 2010 in 2012
were the highest years louisiana just
had its worst season this past year as
did texas which had a monumental year of
1,700 cases plus idaho it was there at
very low levels for four years before it
actually peaked with a big outbreak in
2006 where they got a thousand cases so
there's a lot of variability as to
what's going on there it's not following
any one single pattern we were to
superimpose these on top of each other
so those are the same patterns now but
they're all on the same graph you can
see that the case levels also don't
necessarily reflect the population sizes
again this peak right here is the Idaho
peak and that's not a very popular state
but they had nearly a thousand cases in
California has never reached that level
New York has never reached that level
that's the red the blackish line right
there and Florida has never reached that
level and it's the red line right there
so we're seeing a lot of variability in
what happens and what in what in fact is
responsible for these difference in
these different rates of which people
are getting affected by least based on
population size is not entirely clear
certainly from this initial viewing
there's also a lot of spatial
variability if you start to break it
apart and look at the county level
you'll see that there's a lot of
heterogeneity and what's going on very
heterogeneous field there sometimes it's
clustered around population centers
sometimes yours Mississippi right there
it really isn't so the question is well
what accounts for this variability why
are we seeing some years that are really
bad some years art why are we seeing the
spatial temporal variability that we're
observing so what are the things we have
to think about is the force of
transmission okay and this is a key
determinant of whether there's going to
be spillover transmission okay and one
of the components of that is the number
of infectious mosquitoes that are there
vector mosquitoes that are there that
are feeding on human hosts so the idea
there is that if we hold everything else
constant and we just increase the number
of infectious mosquitoes not the number
of mosquitoes but the portion of those
mosquitoes that are actually infectious
with West Nile virus we would expect
more spill over transmission given
everything else is equal right so one
way that they quantify this incidentally
in this force of infection is through a
designation or a measure that talks
about vectorial capacity and this is a
measure the pressure of transmission
risk their number of ways that this has
been quantified this is the one
published by Garrett Jones in 1964 it's
got this equation where the vectorial
capacity is equal to the vector to host
ratio which is M times the number of
hosts squared times the probability of
the vector surviving for a day
to the nth power where n is then the
time needed to complete that extrinsic
incubation cycle and then divided by
another probability of vector survival
so the idea again is that oops if you
increase the number of hosts or you
increase the vector to host ratio you're
going to be increasing the vectorial
capacity okay and the reason you're
increasing the vectorial capacity you
can just think about the qualitative
terms if you're thinking of it in terms
of just this transmission loop right
here there's 0 anodic cycle in which
you're going to feed the virus between
the mosquitoes and the avian host if you
increase the number of hosts you have
more opportunities to generate
infections okay furthermore if you
increased the ratio of vectors to that
increased host population you're
certainly also going to be increasing
the capacity of the number of bytes that
are going to be going on in the cycle if
you introduce the virus into that system
then where you have an increased in
hosts and an increased of vectors that
even exceeds that increased of hosts
you're going to get an amplification as
it's termed of the virus within this
cycle of transmission so amplification
is a term I'm going to bat around a
little bit here what that is is the
episodic cycling of our virus between
mosquito vectors in AV and amplification
hosts and that is what's considered
necessary to achieve those mosquito
infection rates that are sufficient to
cause human epidemics so when you have
this episode gnosis as it is this
epidemic within that zone otic cycle of
transmission between birds and
mosquitoes you're going to start to get
a lot more infected birds and you're
going to start to get a lot more
infectious mosquitoes if you have more
infectious mosquitoes chance of the one
of those mosquitoes biting a human and
being infectious is going to be
increased and you're going to get more
spillover transmission now the point
when this is going to occur is when the
vector mosquitoes and the avian hosts
congregate together when they actually
come together in both space and time
that's what you need to do to bring this
together to elevate those two terms
right there in the vectorial capacity
equation so to explore this this idea of
colocation and whether this really is
vital we did some agent-based model
simulations and they
support the notion of it so what this is
is this is an an agent-based model
tracks individual birds and individual
mosquitoes flying around in a domain
within it in that domain we've set up
some roosting sites with the birds like
the congregate based on their patterns
of going through their daily habits
we've also set up some over position
sites where the mosquitoes are going to
congregate to lay their eggs and then
from there start to actually post seek
seek blood wheels from that point on
okay so we can set up various
configurations of it and that's what
this plot on the on the right shows you
we have five different routes
configurations and six different over
positioned location configurations so
they're 30 different combinations what
it shows you is the fractions of each
runs in which there was an amplification
of the virus once it was introduced or
whether the virus dried off as the other
alternative within this model simulated
community what you can see here is the
asterisks are the ones where the virus
is introduced into an area where the
mosquitoes and the birds are
cohabitating or concentrating in space
and time and what you can see there is
that those have much higher chances of
actually undergoing an amplification in
this model system than those in which
that's not the case okay where they're
not congregating in space and time so
this seems to be some model support for
the idea the colocation is very critical
some field evidence supporting this that
was done here in New Haven Yale with by
maria de processor is that looking at
what's actually going on in the late
season and whether or not we can see
changes in the estimates of West Nile
virus infection rates within mosquito
communities and what they did indeed
find was in the late season that they
were higher rates of mosquito infection
at communal roosting sites than at non-
communal roosting sites so that's
another piece of evidence that there is
in fact this colocation going on all
right so what does any of this have to
do with climate or whether hydrology
well hydrologic variability influences
mosquito abundance and distribution okay
the first three stages of the mosquito
lifecycle egg pupae and larvae are
aquatic mosquitoes depend critically on
availability of water there are many
different species of mosquitoes and so
they have different requirements so we
have to keep in mind and look
specifically at the mosquito species
that are critical to the transmission of
West Nile
as the case may be so rainfall has two
principal influences on the mosquito
cycle life cycle firstly the increased
near-surface humidity associated with
rainfall affects mosquito flight
behavior activity and their host seeking
behavior some mosquitoes are very
sensitive to this some of them are not
but the ones that are sensitive very
often the weight and they'll hold their
eggs and they won't actually become
active until there's a big rainfall
event near surface humidity levels
increase then they'll go out and they'll
look for someplace to lay their eggs and
then they'll start host seeking at that
point rainfall also can alter the
abundance and type of aquatic habitats
that are available from the mosquito to
the deposited sex for over position the
subsequent development of immature
stages so we have rainfall it's an input
mechanism into those low-lying areas and
the swamps and the river margins the
puddles in the ponds the areas of water
that the mosquitoes exploit for actual
egg-laying and where the eggs larvae and
pupae you go through their life cycle so
my vantage has been well if
precipitation really isn't the thing
that's guiding it but it's feeding into
these larval habitats why don't we try
to track those larval habitats a little
bit more directly so what we do is we
use a hydrology model dynamic hydrology
model to actually simulate the
hydrologic cycle at the land surface and
atmosphere interface right there so
there are a number of things that we can
say about what's going on there using
the hydrology model number of estimates
we can make but one of those is the
estimate of soil moisture conditions or
the water table depth how saturated the
soil is in a given area in a given
locality and what that's going to give
us is an estimate of how much water
there is in the soil and how much of the
lowland areas the swamps the lowland
relief areas that are actually going to
start to puddle and pond and potentially
support the types of habitats that some
mosquito species will exploit and to
show you why this is important this just
shows you some time series of
precipitous sorry a precipitation this
is at a catchment outside New York City
actually near West Point this shows you
precipitation in a small catchment for
one summer season the red line is
temperature the green line is
measurement of river run off at the
little weird that they have on this
river and then this is the model
estimate of the depth of
the water table the point within the
soil the depth within the soil of which
you actually get hit saturated
conditions its measured the water
content over all of the soil and you can
see that the way this varies drawing
through the summer is the heat continues
and then pulsing up if there's a large
enough rainfall event giving how dry it
is the variability of this is very
dissimilar from what you see going on in
the precipitation record so the idea
there is if we can actually constrain
this reasonably well maybe this will
give a better estimate of what's
actually going on and this is a more
direct component of the environment to
which the mosquito species might be
responding so within this hydrology
model not only we including inputs of
rainfall but there are a number of other
things that contribute to the energetics
of the system the drainage water from an
area and its movement between the soil
vegetation in the atmosphere so I'm
going to first talk about an example
from South Florida where we've done
we're going to stay local we're going to
consider it at a localized scale we will
be talking about to pathogens West Nile
virus and st. Louis encephalitis virus
we're going to look at it in a specific
area again South Florida and we're going
to look at it in the context the
specific vector the transmits these
pathogens in this area which is cool its
neighbor palpus so it's no longer this
guy over here but it's this one right
here so st. Louis encephalitis virus has
a very similar transmission cycle as
West Nile virus as a matter of fact when
West Nile virus first came they thought
perhaps it was a new variant of st.
Louis encephalitis virus before West
Nile virus became all the rage and
released supplanted it you could see up
to 3,000 clinical cases per year of st.
Louis encephalitis virus and again the
majority of cases are subclinical mile
there's no vaccine the transmission
cycle is really identical to what you're
seeing for West Nile virus here's the
cubic snicker palpus mosquito the vector
in South Florida it's a ubiquitous
breeder it likes acid swamp slime saints
lakes temporary pools epiphytes it'll
breathe in a lot of locations but it
does have a preference and its
preference is for the puddles and ponds
that develop on the Florida landscape
after rainfall it really likes the more
fresh rain driven puddling that takes
place that often can be filled with some
eutrophic organic matter
that makes it a little choked and fun to
swim around and feed it it feeds on both
mammals and birds and a matter of fact
it has an interesting life cycle where
it's been documented that it has a
tendency to switch midseason from first
speeding on birds to later season
feeding on mammals which can make it a
very efficient vector in the case of
West Nile virus and st. Louis
encephalitis virus as I said it's the
principal vector in Florida and one of
the key things is that during the day it
will rest out of the Sun in dense
vegetation and we'll come back to that
in a moment so there are four phases of
the Florida SLE cycle in Florida inter
in this region the first broadly
categorized in the first quarter of the
year is called maintenance amplification
that key component where you get that
episodic cycling between the birds and
mosquitoes takes place in the second
quarter of the year and then we have two
phases of transmission early in late
season just to complete the quarterly
designations in 1990 they did have an
outbreak of st. Louis encephalitis virus
there were two hundred twenty six cases
reported in florida indian river county
right here where you grapefruits was the
epicenter and over that span of time
they had a number of two pieces of data
that they've been collecting through the
course of this epidemic that we're very
helpful the first two sentinel chicken
transmission data those are the numbers
right here and this is where they posted
sentinel chicken flocks what they do is
they take six chickens they put them in
cages out in the field someplace and
once a week they come along they bleed
them and they look whether or not
they've developed antibodies to the
virus and question in this case st.
Louis encephalitis virus they've
developed the antibodies it's indicative
that they have in fact been infected
within the last two weeks or so they'll
pull that chicken out and put a fresh
one in this way they get a time series
for a specific location of the force of
transmission in that area okay the other
thing that they have at this em right
here was mosquito resting abundance data
as I said they like to rest during the
day in dense vegetation well they went
into a stand of death its vegetation
there and for six years three times a
week they would go along with a vacuum
aspirator and walk along a designated
path and collect mosquitoes and take
them back and count them and sort them
by sex and gray etc so very rich data
sets available for this time period some
more specifics Florida is a subtropical
climate drought occurs seasonally during
the spring and summer is the way
seasoned very different from much of the
rest of the country where spring is
wetter and summer is drier surface water
is heavily managed very flat landscape
there's lots of channelization in the
area to help drain that flat landscape
so you don't get too much flooding and
ponding all over the place and also the
landscape is fragmented so this is what
one of those hammocks looks like where
the mosquitoes might be resting this is
a an area of lush subtropical vegetation
but those only dot the landscape at this
point there's been enough development in
Florida for housing for agriculture that
you have most of that cleared away and
then you'll have little pockets between
those where you have this lush
subtropical vegetation the mosquitoes
like so what we did is we modeled the
hydrology for this area we use this
model we refer to as the top model based
hydrology model it's a bucket model
basically discretize as the soil into
ten layers and then you track the
movement of water and energy between
those layers and between the surface
layer vegetation in the atmosphere it's
really run as a boundary layer problem
it's forced by surface day hourly
surface meteorological conditions things
like precipitation temperature pressure
wind speed humidity etcetera in addition
it also takes into account spa grafika
troll rates of runoff even in the
Florida landscape but we can do with
that by integrating it forward in time
is we can produce a time series of the
estimate from the model of the mean
water table depth for the area that
we're looking at so it's a it's a
relative measure of how dry or wet the
soil is and how much public the ponding
might be supported by that soil at a
given time so that's the blue line right
here you can see this over a six-year
period from january 86 to the end of
nineteen ninety one shows the
variability in hydrologic conditions as
estimated by the hydrology model you can
see there are peaks right here in the
summer and there are low periods right
here which is in spring taking place
okay in addition on hero shown you the
data from those five sentinel chicken
sites and it shows you the weekly rates
of seroconversion of the central
chickens and you can see that there are
only three seasons of the six in which
there was any cereal conversion 1986
1989 in 1990 and in all three instances
that occurred in the season after a
period of drought
during the period of wedding with a big
one taking place right here in addition
you can see that the they all occurred
actually after the three driest seasons
okay so we can do some analysis of this
and we subjected it to a bunch of
statistical analysis and show that in
fact this association is significant in
that drought four months prior and
wedding half a month to a month prior is
significantly associated with the serial
conversion of those chickens here okay
so we see this transmission occurring
after a period of drought immediately
following a wedding period so the
question is why and the basis of the
relationship really came down to the
mosquito collection data taken in this
hammock what these plots show you is
each of the six years during which this
was taken 89 and particularly 90 with
the two really bad years in terms of the
zero conversion to Sentinel chickens in
1990 was the case that was brought emma
demic across must flow much of florida
and the plots show the total number of
females collected as a function of
bottled water table death the same day
measure of the drought okay and what you
can see is that you get a general
increase is it gets wetter and in the
numbers very loose and fuzzy there a lot
of scatter and noise there but on the
two very dry Year's 1989 and 1990
there's a bit of a bi modality at the
very driest conditions you can see
there's an increase in the number of
mosquitoes that are being collected so
that really are two interpretations for
that one is that mosquito abundance
actually increases during very dry
conditions or the latter is that the
mosquitoes are congregating in the
hammocks during droughts and it's
actually the latter lots of
observational evidence lots of anecdotal
evidence I've been down there and
droughts that was done in the Everglades
in the in the drought in 2004 and people
are coming along and they're looking at
the alligators there and they're sort of
having a shrinking habitats the
alligators and they're also these pads
that go into these hammocks stands lush
native vegetation and I was just
standing outside and watch people walk
in the 30 seconds later they come
running out because of the mosquitoes
the mosquitoes are really active in
there and they're all in there you stand
outside them you don't get bit you go in
there you get even alive I tried it
myself once it wasn't fun so they're
there so what do we think's going on
well spring is the nesting season and
the birds are exploiting those hammocks
as well so remember Allah
the Florida landscape particularly in
Indian River County has been cleared the
birds really exploit that lush
subtropical vegetation that's dotting
the landscape and it's the same sites
that the mosquitoes are retreating to
okay what do we have we have
hydrologically induced collocation of
the avian hosts and the vector
mosquitoes we get amplification so
that's what we thinks going on in the
springtime there since then we've looked
at this a number of different ways we've
looked at the transmission of st. Louis
encephalitis virus to wild birds we've
looked at high levels of it epidemic
levels to transmission to Sentinel
chickens throughout the state not just
in cell and Indian River County we've
looked at human cases throughout South
Florida we've looked at human cases of
West Nile virus throughout South Florida
they all present the same relationship
drought followed by a wedding leads to
an increased likelihood that you're
going to see human cases of West Nile
virus elevated levels of Seconal chicken
zero conversion cases of SLE v etc so
our conclusion hypothesis is that spring
drought restricts the [ __ ] Piper's
palpus activity to select refugees those
hammocks where nestling juvenile and
adult birds are found and that forced
cohabitation of the vector in the avian
host permits that rapid amplification of
West Nile virus and st. Louis
encephalitis virus when the drought ends
the infected mosquitoes didn't birds
disperse and they come into broader
contact with humans they start entering
the agricultural plantations they start
entering the housing developments
there's more interaction and contact
with humans and you get this whoops you
get transmission to incidental hosts so
we've been since taken this and tried to
look at some other places again they
have different vector species different
avian host compositions they have
different climates different land-use
practices in them but looking at eastern
Colorado we found a very robust
association that was the opposite it was
wet Springs and dry summers favoring
human West Nile virus transmission okay
so what could possibly be going on when
we have to think about the vectors there
and what their specific interests are
and what we're speculating at this point
we don't have as much data there we
don't have a rich set of entomological
data to look at for instance or the
Seminole chicken data yet is that we
speculate that increased land surface
wetness
produces a greater abundance of mosquito
breeding habits tatts so if they get a
late late winter snowfall that's
particularly heavy you can keep the
ground very wet you can get a lot of
spring melt and tar solace in particular
likes to take advantage of those types
of breeding habitats and you can get a
big bloom in those numbers then when you
have a dry summer you're losing all
those water resources and the birds and
the mosquitoes have to congregate around
those limited water resources and that
can put them in two sympatric you can
get the amplification of the virus in
that instance i think the culet pipiens
particularly exploits that ladder dry
summer mechanisms because it really
likes eutrophic larval habitats we also
think that flood irrigation in eastern
Colorado is a very important confounder
in this that's actually amplifying the
amplification problem because they'll
take the limited amount of water out of
the river system and they'll use it to
irrigate a lot of crop lands and it's
not necessarily done in a way that's not
conducive for producing certain
floodings of the fields if that's the
case you get problems there also also
see a lot of transmission in Colorado
around golf courses in the fort collins
area for instance where they have water
traps that's where the mosquitoes and
the birds will hang out together we've
also done an extended dist and looked at
Long Island New York and in this case
we've been looking at pooled mosquito
infection rates we've compared that we
get the exact same relationship we see a
Colorado and again the climate of
Colorado and New York is a little bit
similar in the sense that they both tend
to have wetter Springs and drier summers
we're seeing sort of a similar incidents
there so one of the things that we want
to do is we want to look elsewhere we
want to start to try to put this mosaic
together by looking at hydrology and
these incidents of West Nile virus the
dynamics of it whether or not there's
this hydrologically induced force
collocation of birds and mosquitoes and
that's consistent with the emergence of
transmission episodes in space and time
so we can do this from a number of
advantages we can use both model
simulations and satellite observations
of hydrology to make these to do this
work and ultimately the idea would be to
try to monitor the whole country
potentially in real time and see what's
going on in the meantime we have set up
a real-time monitoring and forecasting
system in Florida so here we're using
this NOAA NASA NASA
al and data assimilation system project
data to force a hydrology model and
produce simulations of hydrology in
Florida they look something like this
when you do the runs right there and
this is some of the input data that goes
into the model and an hourly clip and
what we do with this observational use
is we use it to actually inform local
County control officials and public
health officials about what's going on
the relationship in Florida is uniquely
so robust at least uniquely at this
point that we're actually almost able to
take the vector mosquito out of the
equation we can just look at hydrology
and use it as a determinant of risk for
West Nile virus at this point Matt in
some sense is what we're doing we've
been able to alert local county
officials when the drought conditions
have been consistent and conducive with
the type of dry down that you see that
permits the amplification of the virus
one the time in this right and the
results are kind of interesting in the
sense that obviously if they take
control measures it's hard to know
whether what we predicted would have
happened would have happened because
they've done something to counteract it
and Florida has yet to have a large
outbreak of West Nile virus which is
curious also very large elderly
population you would have subject that
to be a little bit more susceptible to
it and there'll be more problems with it
but it has not happened yet where they
have had outbreaks have been in small
communities and they've been very focal
and they tend to be wealthy communities
in urban areas what they are is there
are people who are essentially because
they're so wealthy they live inside a
hammock they live inside an area where
they have all that lush subtropical
vegetation because it's great it's
beautiful and basically within those
little islands like coconut grove Miami
the mosquitoes and the birds find their
paradise and they come together when
it's drought so they don't need the
wedding to take place so in fact we
haven't had a really good episode of
drought and wedding as the curd in 1990
since West Nile virus appeared in
Florida we've just had drought that's
occurred and then it just continues to
dry them and having a lot of problems
with drought in Florida so the drought
is sufficient to get the amplification
going in these hot spots within hammocks
but if the mosquitoes don't have that
cue that wedding to disperse they're not
going to affect a lot of people the
exception will be for people who happen
to live in hammocks and that happens to
be the very wealthy areas of areas and
Tampa and Miami etc and that's where
we've seen the transmission so some of
the other issues that we're trying to
think about is well how do we translate
this how do we operationally use this
we're making probabilistic forecasts of
what's going on and how do we use this
information that only really provides
likelihoods to communicate to public
health people that's something that
we've been trying to work on a bit and
trying to sort of engender an
understanding of what their needs are
and also how to better communicate it
and in fact in truth providing
probabilistic forecasts is a much richer
palette of information it's a way to go
rather than claiming that there will be
this event which you're going to be
wrong sometimes you want to get them
distribution of outcomes and an
understanding that their chances of
certain events taking place and there
may not be in other instances okay so
the last thing of course is that well
it'd be nice to really show that the
monitoring system anticipates that huge
epidemic that we think it might happen
in Florida if conditions are right it'll
be really nice if we could actually
avert that epidemic by taking some
proactive measures to counter it but
then the question really is how much
should you do should there really be
incredibly height and targeted control
of vector mosquitoes which they don't do
I mean they will spray more but should
we tell them go into the hammocks try to
clip it really early on in the spring
you have a drought going on try to nip
the amplification in the bud as opposed
to waiting till the transmission season
starts to tell them to really become
proactive so we need to look at this
this requires some more modeling some
even some economic analysis to
understand so in summary we found that
amplification and transmission of West
Nile virus are intrinsically linked to
hydrologic variability in this
association varies from place to place
as the vector mosquito an avian host
composition changes as well as land-use
practices as well as hydrologic and
climatic conditions of a region okay but
if we can account for those differences
we should be able to identify the
different links potentially between
hydrology and West Nile virus dynamics
and that much of this link really comes
about aggregation or consecrate tration
around limited water resources at least
that's what we hypothesize right now we
are doing real-time monitoring and
forecasting and they are possible and
it's in operation in South Florida and
so just to conclude these are my
collaborators include Jonathan day
medical entomologist the University of
Florida
Stiglitz who's a hydrologist at Georgia
Tech and sundry other people Scott
Campbell marcaine very Harding the
coments dcba thanks